wieso spiele ich denn immer wieder hallo
herzlich willkommen zu einem spiel
es ist gerade schon ein bisschen später
am abend ist es nämlich gerade her okay
so what the [ __ ] was jesus ich schaffe
ich das nicht dass ich einfach mal wieso
google dass er wieder so ist denn ihr
wieder für eine scheiße ich will einfach
nur euch eine kleine runde bringen wo
ich irgendwie mit dem helikopter so ein
bisschen rum fliege ich ein bisschen
schön die stadt zeigen und dann bumm
ich bin tot ich darf mal bevor sie gar
kein video coray das ist doch nicht wahr
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein dass
ich einfach diese scheiße um fliege naja
ich hab mir gedacht bevor heute gar kein
video kommt mache ich wenigstens ein
video wo ich es ist ja nicht mal so dass
es schwer ist ein sicherer hafen
es ist ganz einfach so dass es so mega
spät erst reagiert und wegen der steuer
auf wieso ist er reagiert zum mega
schlecht wegen der steuerung und dann
kann man halt nichts machen das ist doch
hier das ich muss doch einfach mal nur
hier ausleben rumfliegen und dann mache
ich mir eben leute schon recht spät
dafür dass heute eigentlich name tassen
video kommen sollte das wetter war so
toll und dann habe ich einen kurzen
spontanen trip gemacht und dann war ich
noch was essen und dann habe ich noch
gelernt alles mögliche und dann hatte
ich nicht also bezahlt und man wieder
einmal dass ich mir jetzt kommt es
einfach heute abend noch so kleines
spiel wo ich mich über einen helikopter
aufreger demski
ich kann doch nichts für ich drücke
jetzt und jetzt reagiert er es ich muss
alles über 10.000 jahre später gleich
denken immer das ist
ob man das leben auch immer selbst
werner ich suche solche spiele mal raus
aber ab ich werde dort nicht gegen
geflogen ich bin ruhig ich hatte das
gefühl dass solche videos immer gleich
aufs gleiche hinaus hoffen ich denke ich
irgendwelche simplen spiele wo ich nicht
viel erklären muss spiel die einfach und
letztendlich kriege ich mich wieder so
auf dass sich zwei tage kopfschmerzen
habe was ich hab gedrückt machen immer
wieder von einem aus kam einfach dass
ich hier mal eben einfach so lifestyle
das ist halt so ein bisschen erkämpfen
cam was macht die diso du sollst dich
hier hinschauen nicht da unten irgendwie
runterrutschen meiner spiel an sich ist
ja auch nicht jetzt ist ja schon wieder
verrutscht aber was ist denn los mit der
like doch einfach gerade auch die cam
problem gelöst
ich gehe einfach hier mit meinem
aussagen ran damit ihr seht wann ich
genau drücke und wann der letztendlich
erst reagiert ich muss immer sagen guck
ich verstehe es nicht
das kann nicht sagen ich drücke die
ganze ich wüsste auch nicht was ich bei
sowas kommentieren soll
ich dachte halt echt ist also ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich anfang vom video gesehen
da stand best 0 also ich hab echt nicht
gespielt hat professor ich dachte halt
nur ist wäre so cool wie das spiel was
es damals mal im iphone und app store
gab wo man hier 3 unterhalt zu drücken
und das ist auch so darum gerungen
classic genau das gleiche aber das hat
noch mehr spaß gemacht und man gab es
auch so eltern sondern kamen aliens und
so ganz aber hier passiert ja nichts
du musst er einfach nur da rumfliegen
und es ist halt immer dahin wo ich
anfangen willst ist den kopf jetzt wiege
ich das erstmal nach unten so ok diesmal
mit ich übrigens falls wieder jemand
meinen zu jahren oder falls das ist doch
nicht wahr auch wenn ich dagegen fliege
dass er okay jetzt steckt da drin aber
wenn ich dann beispielsweise dazu knapp
drüber fliegen will
das ist doch nicht wahr so falls jemand
denkt du auch das video ruckelt bei mir
oder du hast irgendwie falsch geändert
oder sony es ist bei mir halt auch so
scheiße das spiel das ist halt echt
nicht cool
als man diese spiele ich denn komma null
es ist nicht cool das radio
luca hier künstlich aufreger ist doch
nicht cool hier mein mann macht doch mal
hier und sohn die es ist ja nicht
künstlich es ist doch einfach nur nicht
wahr
ich bin ja auch nicht schlecht da drin
das spiel ist einfach nur scheiße es
reagiert also spät bin mir nicht sicher
ob jetzt mein fachwissen falsch an wände
aber dpi oder die preise aber ich gebe
auf ich hab gedrückt ich habe gedrückt
tore fürs übersteuern mein kleines
mikrofon ich meine dpi ist das wie
schnell ich meine dps das wie schnell
die maus hat reagiert also du schreibst
damit so über dein ding also nicht okay
zweideutigkeit fortuné ich glaube dps
doch das wie wie schnell die maus von
der einen seite vom bildschirm zu
anderen geht und nicht wie schnell die
maus reagiert oder auch keine ahnung ist
das scheißegal jedenfalls ist ihr kacke
ich weiß nicht wie ich auf 461 gekommen
bin habe ich das ja mal anfangen
geschafft den highscore wie soll die
fifa also es war ja auf jeden fall im
video aber wie
da ich werde auch nicht ich will erst
mal dass ramos luca bitte hier im
schnitt pac man es mal aussteller reihen
hier wie das da wäre ich mich drüber
geflogen
es ist halt echt ich war auch com
man kann auch nicht so schnell reagieren
dass der bahnhof liegt fliege immer auf
der höhe vielleicht runtergeht noch klar
aber hoch nicht so hoch es geht nicht
ich sehe dieses ding wenn man ein
bisschen weiter drunter ist es ist eine
glückssache hier so drunter her
us dollar ich krieg die krise mit diesem
helikopter das niemals niemals wieder
nie wieder ich nie wieder ein letzter
versuch
ich mache das spiel erstmal mega klein
ihr seht es wahrscheinlich die ganze
website oder irgendwie so die die webcam
acer voll gar nicht im bild hier mal
wieder theorie dass ich dich vor hindu
angemeckert value auf meine maus nicht
fokussiert dass du klein ist ich weiß
gar nicht wie das rüber kommen wenn wir
in ein anderes erstmal zu sieht beim
zocken
so streicht ihm eine webcam schmeißt ihm
eine flasche durchs zimmer
ach mein gott das muss doch jetzt besser
klappen das muss auch irgendwie es
besser laufen oder so aber es lag ja
nicht an der computerleistung aber okay
ich merke schon es läuft tatsächlich
besser also irgendwas kommt zumindest
vor und ich muss jetzt einmal ein
highscore knacken hier sonst 44